and this is so powerful like this
interconnection this moment that you
understand that your technology actually
understood how you feel this doesn't go
away what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sockin
we're still on site for our second
partnership with the transformative
technology conference we're so pumped to
be here we are now going to be talking
about augmented mental health we have
George
I left the rave joining us on the show
hi George hello good thank you very much
for having here we're so pumped for this
conversation George your work is
incredible with my field we're gonna
dive deep into that taking the suffering
out of Mental Health social pumped about
talking about that as before we jump in
there's just so much to talk about
regarding spirituality and feelings of
oneness that we talk to all of our
guests about are we really all one I
think that we are in an emotional level
definitely we are in a spiritual level
like but from a mental health some point
that we see it we can see how much our
emotions affect our surroundings the
people around us our loved ones and
that's just a manifestation of like
being in a united world so what we see
from an emotional at some point is our
actions or behaviors and only affect us
as individuals but our families our
loved ones or friends and ultimately the
world right so that's that's for us the
the living proof of oneness as you said
interesting so the interconnectedness
between all of us at the deepest levels
of our psyche regarding emotions and
just development psychological
development and just the way that the
butterfly effects work and all the chaos
theory that happens there's just too
profound of a level of
interconnectedness in that sense
so then that's where the oneness it lies
really for you I would say the the one
is like for me it starts from the
interconnection of the body and the and
the spirit and of the emotional self and
the physical self and we see this again
going back to to what science tells us
you see individuals that suffer from
chronic conditions such as diabetes or
cardiovascular disorders actually
improving significantly when they take
care of their mental health for us this
is a proof that actually our emotional
self with our physical self are very
highly interconnected and I think from
that standpoint that's the first level
of connection the second level is how
what we do actually affect lives of
others on an emotional level and
physical level of course yeah yeah this
is such a profound one is that the more
that you heal your mental health state
the more that your physical health heals
and health as we know is number one for
your moment-to-moment you know number
one feelings of interconnectedness
feelings of health just the most
paramount absolutely
how about feelings of on this topic
which is the question is do you think
that our disconnection from the feelings
of interconnectedness are the root of
all of the problems we have well I I
don't like to generalize in terms of
like like there's no one reason for the
problems that we have however definitely
the fact that we don't pay attention to
our mental and emotional health and we
only take care for physical health I
think that this effects the way that we
leave the stress that we have in our
daily lives we live in an anxiety
economy as as I was reading in an
article a few days ago an anxiety
economy exactly yeah exactly and you see
all the behaviors that we have in our
lives are affected by by actually not
taking good care of our inner emotional
health so for me absolutely this plays a
a critical role of course in addition
with physical health and and other
well-being activities that we can do but
definitely the emotional self and and
mental health is of primary importance
and then you decided you know all your
answers to all of these questions that
you've been answering so far have been
emotional well-being oriented all of
your answers are regarding that I mean
it does seem like even though you said
that it's an it's hard to just
generalize a room but really this idea
of emotional spiritual well-being um an
interconnectedness is in fact kind of in
the answer correct now you went off and
decided to build a solution using
technology which is kind of interesting
okay so now teach us about what where's
this moment for you that you were like
aha I want to go and take on this
project and build this and then what
exactly is the my field so a few years
ago I was who's a management consultant
was with McKinsey in New York I was
working between 80 and 100 hours per
week so it was pretty hectic and one of
the things that I was not doing was
paying attention to my emotional and
mental health actually was not paying
attention to anything other than work at
the time and one one day after a long
and difficult project I woke up and I
just could not breathe and this was the
manifestation of like not taking care of
my emotional self to my physical health
my gosh you just woke up and I couldn't
breathe yeah good inhale I was really I
had trouble to inhale yeah was it I was
I had had a big trouble to inhale and
actually it was a panic attack this is
what it was like at the beginning I
didn't know that so I went to my
physician and he told me you're fine
everything's good I would get back to
the ER 80 to 100 hours physically but
you need to visit the psychotherapist so
the therapists shortly after and we
started having a few discussions for a
few weeks and then the panic attacks
went away and but what stayed was the
realization that we don't receive any
support for mental health that was one
and also that when you when you receive
psychotherapy or any type of mental
health support there is no objective
data there is no technology involved
like when I was having this panic attack
I didn't know that it was a panic attack
so like oh so that was the inspiration
behind starting our company
my co-founder also a heuristic bus who
is a PhD in biomedical engineering yeah
he's really the brains of the company
and what we were doing was doing his PhD
at the time and he was working on how we
can use data from different sensors in
order to identify human emotions or
other insights so for and for for
healthcare yes
so those two came together I would say
both both of our experiences because I
had struggled with with anxiety as well
our personal experiences struggling with
her mental health plus his subject
matter expertise made us start this
company with the mission of taking the
suffering out of mental health yes and
making everyone in the world living
joyful and fulfilling lives yes and so
going back to what we are doing we are
developing we're bringing objective data
to the field of mental health for the
very first time we're developing a
sensor that can recognize your emotions
throughout the day we can tell if you're
stressed if you're angry if you're happy
if you're sad and then by using this
data point and cognitive behavioral
therapy we help individuals that suffer
from anxiety depression stress to
improve their mental well-being and
emotional well-being this is a very
complicated thing okay of course it
requires a co-founder in biomedical
engineering PhD that has been studying
this but
now the big question is what biometrics
are you taking in how do you parse those
for some sort of signal and then what
sort of cognitive behavioral therapy you
take intervention from do you deliver
after gaining this profile of this
person how often are you taking these
data samples episode so to start from
the from from the latter we we have an
end-to-end holistic solution for
depression anxiety and stress and
burnout that involves our technology
which is doing the remote patient
monitoring on someone else in other
medical fields we would call it we have
the mobile application through which we
deliver real-time proactive
interventions to to improve the mental
well-being of an individual we have a
licensed therapist in our program who is
getting those data and they can one
intervene in real-time as well as use
these data to improve the effectiveness
of their psychotherapy sessions and then
we have an educational psycho
educational curriculum through which
individuals and participants in our
program develop lasting coping skills
for a for mental health so that's like
that's our offering we are offering our
program through health plans employers
and life insurers and in the way that
intro and now at the moment we are
already active here in California and
ain't in Europe as well we will be
expanding soon enough
going what a way to get to scale fast is
to go through health plans if you can
book a big 10,000 person company on
board that's a big deal and it can it
can really help with the emotional
well-being as well as eradicating
suffering yeah and I hope you were going
here but I do still want to ask
so the actual biometrics that you are
measuring yeah this is very tough stuff
to figure out absolutely absolutely so
we have
we have more sensors than almost any
wearable in the market right now we're
not really a wearable device but because
it looks like a wearable device we call
it a wearable will not publicly market
what sensors you have on the device so
we'll have a galvanic skin response and
a galvanic skin response a galvanic skin
electrodermal activity basically thermal
activity yes it's like from the heart
it's from the skin so in this thing but
but from heart to skin electrical
activity so we are monitoring the
response of the autonomic nervous system
different stimuli so what happens when
you experience an emotional state there
are physical sensations that ankle that
come together with the emotion that you
felt right so probably you are feeling
your heart pumping faster when you're
angry or you feel sweating when you're
stressed all those are indicators that
they are telling you that an emotional
stimulus just happened in here so
through skin conductivity heart rate
monitoring skin temperature monitoring
interest we can identify biomarkers that
help us classify what you're
experiencing right then and there
skin electrical activity skin
temperature and heart rate variability
it's a variety of biomarkers from from
those sensors so it's not only the
variability but on the other and it's
all on the wrist and it's able to
measure all the way and then this is so
ridiculous usually you're actually
building in a sense this big catalog or
library of emotional states related to
skin temperature skin electricity and
heart rate heart data it's a so it's at
the beginning there are four five main
categories is the is joy joy calm
sadness and distress as well as them as
the state of stress so have five
categories emotional categories that we
recognize the way calm sadness distress
stress anger basically and then we have
the emotion of stress and stress
so we have those five categories and
based on those we trigger different
interventions going back to like how do
sugar interventions even for joy or calm
yes
yeah like to get them more joy and calm
so actually those are some of the most
effective ones because those are the
moments that help you at your time of
need
so when you have a joyful moment because
you did something that you really enjoy
it we can use that later on at the time
that your stress and provide you a
reminder of this positive moment that
you had and then what kind of a
biometric profile are you reading out
that shows you that I'm angry and then
what is like your intervention or well
if I'm stressed you wonder what is your
intervention so it's personalized
algorithms we're using at the first
level were performing time series
analysis of the data in order to
identify the areas the moments that you
that have significant emotional
information that's one of the most
difficult things in what we're doing so
when we see your data when actually you
felt an emotion and when not so that's
the first level of course it's very
important to take the noise out of those
signals very difficult as well yeah we
have a team of 12 data scientists half
of them are post PhD working on this for
the past three and a half years so it's
it's difficult problem to crack so the
first level is taking the noise of the
signals the second identifying where we
have the appropriate and important
emotional information and then
classifying this this moment in one of
the different categories that that we
monitor so basically the out of the
three signals three basic signals that
we monitor skin conductivity skin
temperature and heart rate we extract
over 200 proprietary indicators that we
correlate with specific emotions but
this is a very personalized model inch
so 200 proprietary indicators and then
those will tell you about their
emotional models and and this is
personalized
it's also then even a step further
personal exactly exactly it's different
to the response your response to stress
or sadness differently might release it
so there are some commonalities and
that's why we do have a pre trained
model but when we actually apply our
model to you we personalize it to make
it much more accurate and right now we
we have accuracy close to 90 percent
both in the lab and outside of the lab
which is but most importantly it's not
about how we are able to recognize the
emotions the important thing is actually
by recognizing the emotional state of
the person we help the individual take
action is about feedback and happening
at the same time system failure and it's
via a like a notification that they're
getting on the ice yes that's correct
have you guys have you guys went into
thinking about other forms of triggering
people into awakening to the good old
shocks or any of the other crazy there
is someone that was actually doing the
shocks states and yeah there's all
different type of look that's what it is
yeah yeah yeah I think they pitched on
shark tank
I think they it was just interesting
that there's just some cool like what
other like this modality is like I don't
hate notifications all my apps are off
on my notifications etc my phone's
always on silent you know so how do I
use it if I'm like that so the what we
have seen to be most effective for our
users is not to send a lot of who
notifications but identifying the
important moments within their day three
to five moments no more than those that
are important for them to take action on
and we say three to five because you
know if I tell you every five minutes
how you feel it doesn't mean anything to
you right but if I select the important
moments the ones that actually you have
to do some work on in order to improve
that's that what makes a difference so
not a lot of notifications but what we
see is that people take great action on
those notifications so eight
percent of the notifications that we
give to the user lead to an action so
our users actually interact with their
mobile phones with our application close
to 40 times per week and they're
performing 15 mental health actions as
we call them per week so those actions
are either mood journaling breathing
exercises meditations or different
exercises that have been assigned to
them by the psychotherapist so they're
very engaged they really and and the the
differentiator is there is the data
point is because we can tell you when
you are stressed and you know this
feeling never never goes away so like I
remember the first when we had like our
first prototypes I was meditating one
day and I I finished my meditation and
then I received a vibration in my wrist
band the slight vibration which means
that you had an emotional moment and I
go back and I see that while I was
meditating I had a moment of pure
calmness and this is so powerful like
this interconnection this moment that
you understand that your technology
actually understood how you feel this
doesn't go away yeah that's that's very
profound I like that one it also kind of
reminds me of you know strategies that
are being used with Meuse and so many
other of the neuro techs biotechs that
are now available where it is just an
immediate closed-loop feedback with you
hearing the birds chirp or getting the
vibration or all these types of things
where you know that you achieved a state
of interconnectedness of one unity of
oneness whatever I also want to ask you
this question because you pointed out I
think it's very important to talk about
there's so there's actually an entire
suite of psychotherapists that are at in
within the my feel ecosystem and then
they themselves are reading out the
emotional states and they they work with
the deployment of these personalized
either mood journals or meditations or
exercising or all these different types
of and yours correct yeah so basically
we we're offering our program as an
alternative to traditional psychotherapy
for depression or anxiety
so the the program includes weekly
sessions with our psychotherapists usual
our sessions are shorter than the usual
the typical 60 minutes because of the
data that our psychotherapists have
interesting so video or video so they
are doing because they know how the
person felt during the week so you walk
in the appointment and your therapist
goes okay what happened on Tuesday there
is so much so you use you start right
away with a very focused discussion
exactly that actually makes the sessions
much more effective and this would be
right into the car accident or the
break-up or whatever happened job career
change exactly exactly and also the
other thing is that our psychotherapists
are able to help at a time of crisis so
remember my example that I woke up and I
could not breathe this was a panic
attack I didn't know what the time but
if I was wearing a field device this
would tell me that we see that you're
very stressed let's do something about
it and if the feeling or this treasure
didn't go away actually it would notify
my psychotherapist and then my therapist
would text me and tell me George I said
that you are really stressed today do
you want to talk so we have proactive
intervention from the side of the
psychotherapist it's so what we're doing
is basically something that in every
other medical field is considered to be
a fact but in mental health doesn't
exist until now combining objective data
with human interventions and
interventions through the technology in
order to optimize the outcomes off of
users and so far the outcomes that we
see are really really encouraging so we
see improvements for populations that
suffer from mild or moderate anxiety or
depression within 3 to 4 months
improvements that move those people from
suffering from moderate depression to
being healthy within 4 months with no
drugs no pharmacotherapy just by
adhering to our program and this is the
most important thing and hearing what
these people say
hearing how these people actually talk
about their feel respond as a guardian
angel this is the the most satisfying
thing for us yeah that's huge
having the people that are using the
service call this like a guardian angel
when your interventions are also so few
like you said three or five a day
it's just concentrated on the most
profound times for you to reach out to
them it kind of gives them like a like
the three or five peak emotional moments
of your day the catalog it's also very
unique like that to be able to like
visualize this data in itself is very
unique and and interesting and so if I
don't have a health plan I can just sign
up on a monthly basis as well we right
now we don't have an open air program
for for direct consumer however we will
be conducting a large study so we would
be welcoming individuals that have
already asked us to participate in the
program we are really really fortunate
to have many people interested in in
participating so if you're interested or
if any one of the people that listen to
us today are interested we would love to
include them in the program in this
study and sign up my field exactly
exactly so they can go to our website
just send us a note and we will include
them in in the study and the study is
looking at be conducted like early next
year so yes that is correct so we'll be
starting in January money
yes and this is gonna be of course
nothing this is going to be of course
their data fully anonymized no one has
access to this data so when I say study
don't mean that we're gonna take the
data and use it in any other way but
what we're trying to do is add many more
people into our program to actually
evaluate the effectiveness of specific
interventions and calibrate it to make
it as effective as possible so that's
why we have opened those studies so if
they go to www.codingcertification.org
pensive you did you guys actually have
to manufacture that yourselves yeah so
you design that and then manufacture
yourselves is it manufactured in China
and then Susan it's you know shipped
here you're up or wherever afterward and
then the cost of that must be at least
several hundred dollars for the we don't
charge for the hardware we charge only
for the psychotherapy sessions so
actually right now if you go to our
psychotherapists and the cost of like
the out-of-pocket cost could be two
hundred three hundred dollars per hour
so our sessions cost just fifty dollars
per session and the goal for us is that
we have the health plan pay for those
sessions instead of the individuals so
instead of the individual is paying any
money out of pocket in order to be able
to provide support as many people as
possible we want to have the health plan
the healthy billion pays my feel then
exactly we don't we don't charge for the
device so we don't charge anything that
user so you provide these companies with
the devices for their employees and then
interesting and then you just get paid
by the health plan exactly Wow
very fascinating um just this this
question and I must ask because it seems
like everything is going in the
direction of measuring a constant stream
of our biometrics and then being able to
predict pathology or to somehow
rejuvenate me to youthful homeostatic
capacity or other thoughts about being
some sort of an AI coach based on my
unique blueprint and gifts that I want
to bring into the world does it totally
feel like it's going in this direction I
think that the AI will help us deliver
many interventions when we can't have a
human delivering those interventions we
don't believe in actually taking the the
human the psychotherapist the coach out
of the loop we still believe that in the
relationship in the therapeutic
relationship between the therapist and
the individual as being a very important
factor of improving mental health so we
but we believe strongly in amplifying
the human in using technology in using
data to make the the job of the human
much more effective and this is what
we're trying to do in our model we we
don't want to to take the
psychotherapists out of the model of
course we want to deliver 24-hour
support to our to our users
through AI but when the second therapist
is not available to provide this type of
support and then the data to the
psychotherapist to provide them with the
strength with the power to serve more
individuals at the same time in the in a
much better and effective way okay and
then this next question and right
alongside that one is do you think that
humanity is a biological bootloader for
digital super intelligence little bit
more about how you're thinking about
that it's an interesting question but I
ask the questions here I mean the like
like if I understand correctly like
you're asking if we are interconnected
not only an emotional level but also on
a biological level is that is that the
question and then is even our
evolutionary purpose is the next order
of where we're going is literally making
digital super intelligence that we act
as a biological bootloader for that
usual super Intel
I this is an interesting subject to be
honest a philosophical one I would say I
think that like definitely there there
are forms that of intelligence are gonna
be created in the future that are
probably very different from what we
have right now definitely AI will be
able to be doing much of of the things
that we probably don't want to do
there are gonna be a few ethical
dilemmas in the engineer future about
the relationship of AI and and humans if
you will I think that I'm not sure if we
are going to be the ones that we were
going to empower this super intelligence
this digital super intelligence I
envision and I'm hopeful that we're
going to be able to
to live and coexist together in a way
that would be actually beneficial to not
only to humanity but to the planet as
well yeah and guess why I prefer to see
that we're gonna have a symbiotic
relationship with with AI and and
digital and intelligence and different
intelligence forms than the ones that we
have today
not that we're going to empower them and
then we're we're not not gonna be around
for that like I don't like a matrix
Janerio to happen I would prefer like a
life where we you know we're able to use
AI so we can focus on the more creative
stuff the day.i
is not good at doing oh it's permutation
capacity just out I'll place us by leaps
and bounds and then why yeah yeah and is
this the first like the first generation
of AI or are we a I ourselves yeah it's
like it's like a very philosophical
discussion interesting one but I think
that I have our true what is the purpose
of this creation of our creation you
mean of this so great question as well I
would say it's from my perspective again
I can only speak for myself is how can
we enable collective emotional
intelligence how we can actually improve
that as individuals and as a society as
a unison that that would be like my my
interesting your because you're all on
like the flowering of consciousness
exactly yeah this evolutionary process
especially at an emotional well-being
level collectively flourishing and with
the entire interconnectedness of all and
not just humans but all all I love this
last question is what is the most
beautiful about this about this future
about this reality about the screw
what is most beautiful again most of my
answers are gearing towards like mental
and emotional health but for me it's the
the absence of suffering that comes from
in many cases not only from physical
health issues but also from our
behaviors our mental health but not only
the absence of suffering as well as the
existence of vitality and like joy for
me it's all about how can we live a life
of joy and love and when we are
suffering this makes it much harder to
do that whoa George thank you so much
for coming on the program
oh that was extremely extremely
enjoyable for me I'm so happy to hear
that thank you thank you thanks for all
the great work with my feel holy cow
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate we'd love to hear thoughts in
the comments below in the episode let us
know what you're thinking on all the
epic on conversation points that we hit
check out the link in the bow to my
field doc Co also Twitter is your
preferred platform tweeter Facebook is
good too okay great go follow those
links in the bio below as well hopefully
you can partake in the January a 2020
study as well go get involved this
sounds super exciting super
future-oriented eradicating suffering
focusing on emotional well-being check
out the links in the bio below to the
transformative technology conference as
well check out all those links in the
bio below you shout out to them if you
shout out to brady stronger thank you
very much for co-producing greatly
appreciated brother thank you thank you
and also check out the links to
simulation in the bio below help us grow
help the artists the entrepreneurs the
spiritual leaders the organizations in
your communities grow you can find our
patreon crypto-currency paypal links in
the bye below you can also find the cool
link to design cool merch and get paid
all those links are in the bio below go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world you love you
very much thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace
[Music]